look who is cooking in the kitchen
hey chef north
kim kardashian and kanye west's little
girl north
just flexed some mad skills in the
kitchen
and seriously i'm impressed i love that
on wednesday the keeping up with the
kardashians star hit up her insta story
to document her seven-year-old daughter
preparing a pot of instant ramen noodles
with the help of her little sister
three-year-old chicago and their cousin
rob kardashian's four-year-old daughter
dream
you can't be near the fire okay
what is what is um chef northey making
and chef shy shy and chef dreamy what
are you guys making
okay who wants to mash it up okay but
what are you guys making
hi okay can you can you explain to me
this delicious meal
is anyone else like really craving
instant ramen now
can you tell me though what's your
specialty
please
oh this looks delicious can you explain
to me what
is in your meal please poor kim was
really trying to get north to walk her
through the process
but the girl is in the zone and
a pretty cute little leader i gotta say
okay try to mash it
don't get the water up here to here
or do you want me to show you the sound
okay get back
what sound likes oh no
let's not yes okay so let's add
whiz in the kitchen to north's long list
of skills which
of course include wrapping
[Music]
what a beautiful masterpiece i knew she
would be such a great artist
right north of course after the kkw
beauty founder shared
this pic of her daughter north's
impressive artwork
the haters did what the haters do and
started
questioning whether the seven-year-old
actually painted the landscape herself
but kim she was having none of that i'm
really freaking out
and shared this lengthy message on her
insta story which read in part quote
don't
play with me when it comes to my
children having kids
is just there's no way to describe it
but it's a lot
and she reminded us that back in the day
for kim's first
mother's day ever and then baby north
went full-on pablo picasso
and finger painted a very pricey irma's
bag for her mama
i just wanted to look at this
masterpiece guys
this bag north painted for me
when she was not even one years old
what a beautiful masterpiece i knew she
would be such a great artist
right north
you